sounds do you want to open for me
[Laughter]
my brother i i you know he listens to
this and i mean my brother whispers
words and sometimes whispers the wrong
words to emphasize things do you know
that
like you know when people go uh
so and so had cancer
you know you you know that being a jew
they always whisper that or you know uh
you know uh sheila she died you know
they did the people will whisper
generally a negative whisper or a secret
right but my brother will whisper on the
wrong word he'll go i'll meet you in the
lobby let's take the elevator sure yeah
why are you whispering that word
how if you have to take a big [ __ ] just
do it in the bathroom right
all right well that is lou thank you for
joining us lou
oh my gosh come on the other way listen
let me ask you this lou your counters
ever wake up in the middle of night with
a toothache and think [ __ ] i'm closed
tomorrow well it depends what time it is
if it's 2 30 30.
that was a double bubble
that's from double bubble i don't know
double level that's the the the
chewing gum didn't have the jokes in
them didn't you have oh i doubt it's
from that it's maybe in it this is
another on or in the spectrum just
because it's in something doesn't mean
it's from it you never bought the bubble
gum and then you saw the joke buddy
people my age don't go and buy bubble
gum
you know that's a different generation
what do you kids chew on well i'm not a
kid anymore but when i was a kid we
would buy like magic cards or nudie mags
we weren't buying bubble gum and when
you were a kid you're buying bags
when i was a teen when i was
13 or so i was in this um before i had
to go to a special school pep positive
education program i'm not sure if you
know about this none of my education was
positive well it was it was like for
troubled kids you were you were a
troubled people i don't i no judgment to
the troubled
well it depends on what the trouble was
you know
but uh i went to a school that was for
like it was right before you go to juvie
or right after you got out of juby and
like in every class there was a teacher
when you say juvie you're not talking
about yeshiva i'm talking about that
when you're studying your torah portion
that's what i'm talking about that's
what i'm talking about uh and there was
a restrainer in every class so when kids
would jump out the window or run around
there would be somebody that would hold
like you walk into the bathroom there's
just kids being held down get the [ __ ]
off it was like
like a more realistic version of what
scared straight would be if it was an
actual school why did you get sent to
that
i was in a learning disabled class first
and then there was like a sub learning
disabled class i've talked about this on
my pod before uh i remember i was they
they put me in um i was at a desk and
they put blue tape around and i wasn't
allowed to leave so as a 12 year old
who's hyperactive of course i'm going to
do this stuff
you know pushing your foot on put out or
you can't touch hard crawl around on my
knees and i'd be a hyper weirdo but
yeah i mean i also i get
nervous when i repeat stories but i
didn't tell it on here you never told
this on here um and i didn't listen to
that episode of yours
when you were there um
you know uh uh
people would um
take a pin and like stick it through the
dead skin of your fingertips yes um i
would do that uh and they were uh taking
notes of me that i never knew about and
it was ricky stabs himself
uh rick burns himself with cigarettes i
had a little mark from tough actons and
acton because i found a spray and if you
do it upside down um i've never smoked a
cigarette my life but it was all these
things what's tough acting tonight
foot it's like can't do
air thing upside down and spray it stuff
comes out that's what lou's been doing
for the last 10 minutes on the podcast
that's what he's been wearing into his
mouth why don't you keep that a secret
you know i just finished writing a book
called called how to turn fifty dollars
into forty dollars this is the stuff
that casino owners want you to know and
that book is still available i got
twenty dollars if you give me 15 minutes
uninterrupted
so
and then speak up when his 15 minutes is
up and let lou shut up for 15 minutes
got it okay and that that's
predominantly the cause word will come
out of my mouth
coughs for the next 15 minutes
shut up
um so they would say all these things
about uh me that i didn't know about
and then like there was a report at the
end of the year and on top of the things
that i was doing just like yeah you know
running around i remember i remember i
was in half day i was in that class for
half the day and the other half i would
get to go to a couple of classes but all
the teachers knew that i was like this
bad boy or whatever so like you know
look out for rick um also don't touch
his palm because he'll freak
and uh i remember i went
talking about myself somebody else being
me it's so weird
that's what i'm saying people have been
saying this that the only difference is
i don't buy bubble gum
so i remember went to the bathroom i
went to the bathroom and i came and i
was coming back down the hall and uh a
friend of mine shout out to david price
will put his instagram heal here
he's we still laugh about this sometimes
because he'll go she went
uh yelling ricky's on the loose ricky's
on the loose i was in the bathroom i'm
taking the piss and washing my hands
probably the only one in the class
um but there was a whole bunch of stuff
so then i i didn't get to go on the
washington trip i don't know if that's
out here but you go to washington every
a lot of schools and and i wasn't
included in stuff and i already wasn't
really included with friends so like i
just was so far removed and i wasn't
embarrassed yet because i didn't really
realize what it was i just remembered i
it felt bad i didn't like it and then in
ninth grade the only way to get out of
this class which was a full-time class
oh the reason i brought this up by the
way was
uh there was a kid in that class that
bought me a playboy but anyway
um
[Music]
you